I like to ask questions that I think are deep
and difficult and beautiful.
The esthetic sense of what makes a question
elegant and beautiful matters a lot to me.
And then I try to pick problems where I can
make progress.
Some problems are beautiful, but I impossibly
out there.
So I do feel that the way you build your great
edifices is by putting bricks in place.
The thing is, very often you can actually
do that for things that you would think would
be impossibly difficult.
So it's a matter of just being creative and
bringing to bear tools that you've learned
from different fields and putting them together
in a different way.
I'm a theorist and I work in sort of broadly
across multiple areas of physics, theoretical
neuroscience and computer science.
So, you know, in my daily work, I move smoothly
between all these fields.
I'm doing them all at the same time.
My Ph.D. and my training was in, you know,
the fundamental laws of nature the nature
of space and time, gravity and black holes
and the early universe and how you quantize
the theory of gravity.
So that's a core component.
What I do is thinking about, you know, basically
the foundations of physics and the fundamentals
of what space and time are.
They've clearly been interested throughout
my career in the nature of information, what
it is and how it appears and is processed
by systems in the natural world.
I've been interested in questions of the one
hand like black holes and do they destroy
information?
Basically, Hawking's famous paradox, you know,
how is that possible?
On the other hand, I've been interested in
questions like how can neural systems take
information from the world and code it and
then transmit it to the central brain.
There's another clearly a chain that's been
running through my work, which which has to
do with the notion of complexity.
I've written a whole series of papers at various
points about how some kinds of physical dynamics
produce complex states of matter and others
don't.
Basically going after the question about how
physical and biological processes can produce
complexity from states that weren't complex
to start with.
So overall, you know, I'm interested in the
laws and principles that govern the organization
of systems in nature, whether they be living
or non-living And so I sort of tend to spend
a rather enormous range of scales.
I guess while there is a lot of talk of interdisciplinarity
in academia, in practice, In fact, it's a
it's somewhat more rigid than that because
basically you get a degree in a field.
You are rewarded for performance in a field
by the standards of that field.
So navigating the sort of doing multiple things
that kind of career requires some care in
the sense that you have to establish street
cred in the disciplines separately.
The people in each field accept that you're
worthy of the standard of being an expert
in that field.
Maybe knowledge doesn't have to be cut that
way.
When I was seven, we were living in Calcutta
in India, and we used to go to the market
and they have these booksellers I saw how
and why Wonder book The Lives of Famous Scientists.
I remember thinking, Wow, you can do this.
It just seemed amazing, right?
I mean, these people just sat around and figured
out what the world was like.
Physics as a discipline.
I used to see it anyway as the most fundamental,
right?
It's the basic laws from which everything
else is built.
So it was clear I'd be a physicist, but I
think as I began to go through high school
and learn to program machines and stuff like
that, that occurred to me that if computers
that I could program were constrained in what
they could do by the nature of the circuits
they have, then surely I am, too.
So I began to feel that there was a problem
with my understanding of the laws of nature,
and that I clearly needed to understand how
were able to think the thoughts that we're
able to think.
I was a junior fellow of something called
the Harvard Society Fellows, which is not
affiliated any particular lab.
You could do whatever you want.
So I use that freedom to sort of moonlight
in neuroscience labs and basically learn the
subject.
And by the time you know how to master a different
toolkit, I would say than most people.
I knew lots of things in theoretical physics
and do lots of math and tons of computer science.
One of my first papers as a graduate student
occurred because I had just learned general
relativity and therefore knew how to work.
Describe the mathematics of differential geometry
and curved spaces.
And at the same time I had been thinking about
the question of Occam's Razor.
Is there a mathematical reason why a simple
explanation in some sense is actually a better
description of a phenomenon?
And I started thinking about the geometry
of the space of mathematical models as explanations
using the tools I just learned by studying
general relativity.
That was my first paper as a graduate student
and it was very well cited and all that kind
of stuff.
And I really enjoyed that because it was just
putting together pieces that people hadn't
really put together before and kind of assembling
these all into a story.
I have many tools in the toolkit, so with
my students and post-docs, we've been basically
deploying those tools.
When we were thinking about the circuits in
the brain, there's something called the grid
cell system.
Make the maps that you have of the world.
We realized that the self-organizing dynamics
of this neural circuit is an analogy of classic
self-organizing problems in condensed matter
physics, in particular something called the
frontal control of a model that we were able
to take and say, Oh, great, but what we need
is a two dimensional generalization of this
thing.
So once we realized that we were able to guess
how to organize a system of neurons, to have
a dynamics to produce these kinds of hierarchical
maps of the world.
So the idea came directly from knowing some
problems and convinced modern physics For
me, literature matters a great deal.
You know, I spent much of my childhood summers
reading books.
My imagination was basically formed by reading
these stories.
The liberal arts really are getting short
shrift in our world today.
I think it's extremely dangerous because I
don't think of science and technology teach
us how to live.
I think the liberal arts teach us how to live
the dangers of becoming unmoored from our
cultures.
And our histories that our pasts are on ample
display around the world.
If there isn't a healthy society to support
science, science will die.
Even the history of science and sociology
of science matters.
We often have this heroic narrative of the
world was in darkness, and then great Person
X came along and had this deep inside.
And then all of a sudden all was good and
we knew something.
That's not the way science works.
There's the sea of developments that made
that possible, and that matters.
In my own teaching, what I do is I try to
use literary examples and analogies every
week in addition to the sort of science stuff.
We would keep aside half of one class to read
something from literature and something to
contextualize.
So this is in the first chapter of Swann's
Way, the first book of the Remembrance of
Things Past by Marcel Proust.
So he says, "For many years already, everything
about Combray had ceased to exist for me when
one day in winter, as I returned home, my
mother, seeing that I was cold, suggested
that I have a little tea.
She sent for one of those squat plump cakes
called Petite Madeleine.
That look as though they have been molded
in the grooved valve of a scallop shell.
But at that very instant, when the mouthful
of tea mixed with cake crumbs touched my palate,
I quivered.
Suddenly the memory appeared.
That taste was the taste of the little piece
of Madeleine, which on Sunday mornings had
come to my Aunt Leonie would give me after
dipping in her infusion of tea or lime blossom.
I think it's just a remarkable document about
the power of taste and smell to evoke memories.
Silence is great, but, you know, every time
you walk around, it's good to know what's
around you, what made the world, what makes
the world and sustains the world is the culture
and society, the people around you.